this had been a book a radio play and a
stage play so how long did it take to
make it into a film and how difficult
was it because at one point Maggie Smith
said that the film is more concentrated
than the play I don't know what she
meant by that do you know what she meant
by that yeah um yeah I think so Alan
wrote his memoir of the 20 years she was
in gloucester crescent and the 15 years
she was in his drive about six months
after she died in 1989 it was a few
years later six or seven years later
that he first said to me after after the
manners of Georgia third he said that he
was working on making it into a play the
play opened in 1999 the radio was the
play was it was it was simply an
offshoot of the eighth of the stage play
we all went our separate ways in 99
Maggie and Alan and I Alex wasn't in the
play and returned to it two or three
years ago after Alex had played alan for
the first time in Alan's short
autobiographical plays untold stories
which we did at the national theatre
during the 12 years that I Rama National
Theatre Alan was more or less house
dramatist and it was Alex's Alex's
performance as Alan which brought us
back to this material really and Maggie
was up for it so when she says more
concentrated I think what we're talking
about is the smallness of the canvas of
this film this is not a you saw it's not
a huge film it's a film about a very
tiny corner very specific corner of the
world and if I had to point to the chief
difference between the film and the play
it is that the film brings you closer to
her and focuses more intensely on this
tiny drive and this study I think you're
probably aware that we shot it very
happy
we shot it be in Alan's house in his
study looking out onto the drive
Gloucester Crescent is barely changed in
150 years let alone the last 30 so it's
it's the focus of it the narrowness of
the focus which I think she was talking
about and mr. Jennings you had a double
challenge because this had been
performed by other people this role
apart from you and then you were playing
alan bennett who is renowned as a writer
and as a character and a performer in
his own right yes i mean it it helped
having known alan for about 25 years we
first worked together as actors in a BBC
series uh and he's always sort of been
there in my life I suppose from watching
his work on TV his documentary work in
which he often featured and he's a huge
cultural figure in the UK and much
beloved and Alan's said that he
suspected that I'd always been doing
Alan Bennett and he behind his back yeah
and which is kind of true and i just
have now had the opportunity to go
public with it um and it's it's weird
you know playing real people and
especially somebody that you know very
well and are very fond of um it's kind
of spooky I since you played to Alan
Bennett's was this twice the salary I
hope [ __ ] jinnah it what it may have
been but they didn't tell me that it was
it was great and he was around a lot
during filming which was immensely
helpful um was it because that was my
question is whether or not having the
writer there supervising this very
intimate big part of his life was
helpful or not well where I've directed
seven eight of his plays he's three
movies we've collaborated on I come from
the theatre I'm not a not a filmmaker I
I both I'm a theatre director who has
had the good luck largely because of
Alan Bennett to make a handful of films
it wouldn't occur to me it doesn't occur
to us in the theatre not not to
collaborate with writers this is his
film and this is a story that
at least to my American eyes could have
been sentimental or brutal and it
managed to negotiate somehow between
them and I think at one point Maggie
Smith was was quoted as saying that
she'd asked that you said that she'd ask
you to push back if she became too
demonstrative on screen yeah she needs
she needs no telling how to act in the
for the camera or for an audience of a
thousand what she is is extraordinarily
extraordinarily restless hard on herself
she is like a lot of very great actors
um she has a mysterious relationship
with her talent it is almost as if
sometimes chic she treats as if it's
coming from elsewhere she takes herself
a back by what she does so what she
wants from her collaborators from her
director as well as from other actors
are people who kick back because I think
a thing that that she dislikes and his
impatient wave um are those who shrink
from her I mean it's a that it's she's
um she is fiercely fiercely gifted and
unbelievably smart about what she and
every else is doing on the lack of
sentimentality that is that is alan that
is how he recorded um his strange
relationship with this very difficult
woman um the neighbors many of whom is
still there living in Gloucester
Crescent none of them it can be said
remember her fondly she was not easy and
when he says halfway through the film
you couldn't do a good turn without
thought of strangulation um that's
honestly the truth I'm it takes him a
movie to think about why he let this
happen but quite plainly once she was
there um her will was stronger than his
and she drove him demented and if you
ask him how did you grow what did you
learn how did she change you he would he
would dismiss those questions as beside
the
point and he would certainly dismiss him
a sentimental questions and it's
certainly just as she as a performer and
a character resisted sentimentality it
seems like he didn't want to be even
accused of doing a good turn he's
Allen's absolutely adamant that he
didn't do it out of kindness that he
says he did it out of laziness because
she was interfering with his work
because he was worried about her being
out in the road and being hassled by
kids and things and he thought if he
offered her some as he thought it would
be just for a few weeks sanctuary he'd
be able to get on with his work and the
amazing thing of filming it in the house
where it all happened having known this
story for a long time from Alan's
Diaries the the sheer kind of
claustrophobic physical nightmare of of
it isn't is extraordinary you literally
open Alan's front door and you were
faced with the van and you'd have to
kind of do a big banana round the van to
get out into the street um when we we
rehearse the film primarily just the
four of us myself and Maggie and Nick
and Alan for a couple of weeks before we
started shooting and even though we've
known him and known the story we said we
still can't quite understand how you
allowed it to happen and he said well
she didn't really impinge um which when
you're there and you're seeing the van
is sort of impossible to get your head
round were there any changes to the
story the character the van itself that
had to be made for cinematic reasons no
I don't think so this to be near we
built it is mostly true but almost all
its departures from the truth are
advertised and discussed in the film
he's an extraordinary scrupulous writer
he's a historian by training it was a
real effort for instance with the
madness of King George to get him depart
to depart from exact historical truth in
any way at all here he wrestles with his
conscience when he speculates about her
so much of what he found out about he
found out in the weeks after she died
when he finally discovered she had a
brother she left a no
you see exactly the note in the film
addressed to mr. Bennett if necessary um
asking asking him to arrange her funeral
and giving him the address of his
address and telephone number of her
brother so a lot of what he threads
through the film he only found out after
she'd gone and the sense of waste of
regret that Maggie so brilliantly plums
in the film he never saw that in her she
was armor-plated so that's speculation
and that is invention and there one or
two narrative devices the the
blackmailing policeman is a composite of
various people who he observed
tormenting her over the years but it's a
way of introducing the story of the
accident true the the fact that she was
twice thrown out of a convent when she'd
of the common when she tried to when she
was a novice when she tried to become a
nun true the past is a pianist
absolutely true she was a pupil of
Alfred Court oh um that was a huge big
deal he was the great virtue of the
great European virtuosic the
particularly of the early romantic
repertoire the shop our repertoire
between the wars all that absolutely
true so where it manipulates that truth
um the two parts of Alan agonize about
it in the film so it's it's it's pretty
up from with its audience well thank you
both Alex Jennings and Nicholas Hytner
will you thank them for us food